[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes de grands thèmes comme
tous les soirs pour analyser l'actualité
en profondeur mieux comprendre aussi les
crises que nous traversons voici le
sommaire de ce 18 avril 100 jours la
référence et napoléonienne évidemment
elle fait surtout penser aux trois
premiers mois d'un premier quinquennat
mais c'est pour relancer son second
mandat Emmanuel Macron l'a utilisé hier
même s'il a joué aussi la carte de
l'apaisement avec les syndicats c'est un
défi qu'il lance aux partenaires sociaux
et à la première ministre Elisabeth
borne pour inventer notamment un nouveau
pacte de la vie au travail en décortique
les enjeux du prochain trimestre dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
débat on donne la parole au soldats
français blessés psychiquement
un jour ça attiré un peu plus près que
nous mon chef l'adjointe du chef de bord
a pris une balle dans la tête en fait
dans ma tête c'est pas la violence de la
de l'action c'est surtout de me dire
c'est toi qui lui a demandé de de passer
à ta place voilà c'est ça a été un gros
sentiment de culpabilité pour moi donc
j'ai traîné sans trop en parler
pour ces militaires on parle de syndrome
post-traumatique combien sont-ils en
France que fait l'armée pour les aider
pourquoi et comment leur traumatisme
fragilise aussi leur famille beaucoup de
questions abordées des témoignages à
entendre dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord le jour d'après pour
Emmanuel Macron qui recevait le patronat
à l'Elysée ce matin Jonathan Dupriez
tourner la page des retraites et
relancer son quinquennat c'est ce
qu'espère le chef de l'État au lendemain
de son allocution télévisée Emmanuel
Macron c'est aujourd'hui affiché à
l'Elysée au travail avec le patronat et
la volonté d'entreprendre de nouvelles
réformes notamment un pacte sur la vie
au travail une occasion pour le
locataire de l'Élysée de tendre la main
au syndicats ayant boycoté la Réunion la
porte est ouverte évidemment et que on
puisse après le 1er mai avoir les
organisations syndicales qu'ils
souhaitent rentrer dans la définition au
fond d'un agenda social et l'objectif
qu'on doit se donner je dirais jusqu'à
la fin de cette année pour pouvoir bâtir
ce pack si vous êtes prêt organisation
syndicale organisation patronale à aller
plus vite nous nous sommes totalement à
disposition mais je veux dire je veux
pas donner le sentiment de brusquer ce
qu'on ouvre à la négociation en
parallèle le gouvernement a multiplié
les annonces de futurs chantiers sur le
pouvoir d'achat notamment ou encore
l'immigration une feuille de route très
dense qu'Elisabeth borne doit présenter
la semaine prochaine Emmanuel Macron se
donne 100 jours pour agir l'opposition
n'y crois pas héraille déjà la formule
il n'y a qu'à voir cette phrase sur les
100 jours on se dit avec tous les
communicants qu'il a autour de lui
toutes les équipes de gens qui ont fait
l'ENA et qui en épingle qui lui dit
écoute et sans jour c'est grave ça se
termine à Waterloo à Sainte-Hélène parce
qu'il est tellement hors-sol tellement
déconnecté tellement dans un délire de
toute puissance qu'il y a forcément une
dimension psychanalytique en voulant
accélérer le cours de son quinquennat
Emmanuel Macron fait le pari d'enjamber
la crise des retraites sauf que la rue
reste mobilisée et les syndicats bien
décidés à faire du 1er mai une
démonstration de force du côté des
parlementaires de gauche le combat
continue lui aussi nous en parlerons
entre nous avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires qui se sont mobilisés
notamment en déposant le rip et encore
le Conseil constitutionnel qui doit
rendre sa décision le 3 mai prochain il
y aura cette belle mobilisation le 1er
mai la journée du travail nous
continuerons de nous battre sous
pression l'exécutif se donne donc un
trimestre pour sortir du blocage mais le
rebond semble mal engagé à ce stade sans
l'appui de l'opposition ni des forces
vives du pays
pacte de la vie au travail justice et
ordre républicain refondation des
services publics voilà les trois
chantiers annoncés hier par Emmanuel
Macron avec donc ce calendrier serré
premier bilan dans 100 jours on
décortique les enjeux des trois
prochains mois avec Bruno kotrèze
bonsoir vous êtes polytologue chercheur
CNRS et aussi bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi directrice générale de cantar
public Jacques et Jean-Marie Pernaut
bonsoir bienvenue politologue chercheur
à l'Institut de recherche économique et
sociales et votre livre le syndicalisme
d'après aux éditions du détour emilyse
appalski bonsoir Émilie spécialiste en
communication politique éditorialiste
pour sens public bienvenue à vous Bruno
cotress alors évidemment ce qui nous a
frappé cet effet pour hier c'est ce
rendez-vous donné aux Français 14
juillet premier bilan 100 jours pour
enclencher des nouvelles réformes bon
mais mais il y a aussi les images de
cette journée un Emmanuel Macron avec
une table vide de représentants
syndicaux est-ce que le maître des
horloges a toujours la main sur le
calendrier c'est poser des questions du
jour je trouve oui c'est un peu le
problème dans lequel il se trouve parce
qu'effectivement il ouvre la porte mais
les autres ne rentrent pas dans la pièce
donc ça c'est un peu un problème et en
plus il y a les organisations patronales
qui sont là donc c'est vrai que ça
envoie un signe un signal qui a un
signal pas terrible on va dire du point
de vue de la restauration du dialogue
social et le chef d'État n'est pas
arrivé avec son allocution à
véritablement faire ce qu'il voulait
c'est à dire solder la question de la
réforme des retraites et avancer un pion
je pense qu'il a avancé moi deux pions
importants hier avant c'est un premier
pion qui est de créer ce nouveau pacte
sur la vie au travail pour obliger d'une
certaine manière les syndicats à venir
négocier en disant chiche que sur ces
questions là ça vous intéresse pas et
vous êtes capable d'expliquer à vos
adhérents que vous ne voulez pas vous
intéresser aux conditions de travail aux
rémunération à la formation puis il y
avait le deuxième pion qui était un
petit peu à la fin avec une référence au
CNR à nouveau avec la Fondation la
Fondation mais c'est vrai que de l'image
d'une chaise vide d'une certaine manière
n'est pas optimale alors ça va est-ce
que c'est trois chantiers annoncés par
Emmanuel Macron correspondent aux
principales préoccupations des Français
aujourd'hui alors il y en a évidemment
bien sûr mais déjà juste pour rebondir
un petit peu sur ce que sur ce que vous
disiez et sur les clés du temps
notamment moi ce qui m'a marqué hier
soir c'est justement cette question de
tempo un décalage de tempo c'est-à-dire
que le président n'a pas l'air sur le
même tempo que les Français les Français
ils sont sonnés par plusieurs mois de
tension
par le sentiment de pas avoir été
entendu pas avoir été écouté certains
disent même méprisés ne pas sonner aussi
par le fait que finalement la démocratie
a du mal à bien fonctionner aujourd'hui
que les corps intermédiaires ne sont pas
entendues etc et au lieu finalement de
faire un point là-dessus et dire ok
prenons 10 minutes un quart d'heure 20
minutes je sais pas mais en tout cas
prenons le prétexte de cette allocution
pour faire un point que je vous dise moi
finalement pourquoi j'ai fait ça etc
éventuellement d'ouvrir la porte mais
d'ouvrir la porte sur un chantier pas 10
chantiers là le problème il y a sur les
13 minutes il y a peut-être trois quatre
minutes sur sur la retraite et bon une
sorte de mini mais elle coule pas sur le
thème on va voilà elle n'est pas
acceptée donc en creux ça veut dire
qu'on l'a pas bien expliqué ou en tout
cas fait accepter aux Français et puis
tout le reste effectivement c'est sûr
effectivement donc il a il a tout balayé
il a la première préoccupation de
français c'est le pouvoir d'achat la
balaie mais assez vite ça fait pas
partie quand même des trois piliers
qu'il a annoncé si c'est enfin c'est
intégré au nouveau pack sur la vie au
travail
il y a quand même vraiment la question
de de l'inflation la question
effectivement vraiment de la vie
quotidienne des Français et c'est là où
encore une fois il a peut-être raté une
opportunité de pouvoir justement parler
et ancrer son discours dans quelque
chose de beaucoup plus réel et puis un
troisième point je pense qu'il a aussi
beaucoup parlé d'une France qui avance
de progrès etc et les Français je pense
qu'ils sont pas vraiment pareil ils sont
un petit peu en décalage je suis pas sûr
qu'il soit au niveau de cette France qui
avance les Français ils sont plutôt en
attente d'une France déjà qui se
réunissent parce que avec c'est c'est
c'est ces derniers mois justement de
désignant et même ces dernières années
parce que je j'aurais envie presque de
repartir avec la crise covid l'Ukraine
etc tout ça c'est très fragilisant pour
les Français et donc moi je pense que en
tout cas dans ce qu'on voit dans nos
données d'opinions ce qu'attend les
Français c'est davantage finalement de
de forme de collectif renouvelée et là
hier on l'a pas eu au contraire et ce
matin encore moins Jean-Marc Arnaud il a
pas réussi à inventer effectivement une
nouvelle forme ou donner un nouveau
rendez-vous comme il a pu le faire par
exemple après la crise des des gilets
jaunes comment vous l'analysez vous ce
effectivement ce qui peut apparaître
comme une contradiction la France a
besoin d'apaisement c'était les mots
employés par Elisabeth borne et puis lui
il nous donne peut-être même s'il a
parlé d'apaisé aussi il nous donne quand
même plutôt le sentiment de vouloir
accélérer ou l'analyser ça paradoxe ou
cette contradiction
parler va je pense que le problème de la
parole présidentielle c'est que c'est
une parole il aurait été élu l'an
dernier encore on pouvait ça pouvait
être un discours acceptable mais il y a
tant de fois où il a tenu ses paroles au
moment de la crise covid au moment des
gilets jaunes le changement de méthode
etc quand il a été réélu il a dit oui
moi aussi et pendant la crise covid il a
dit moi aussi je dois changer après il a
dit je vais repasser par le dialogue
social il a refait un peu le numéro hier
soir sur le dialogue social mais le
problème c'est que maintenant tout le
monde a donné pour voir quoi donc ça
manque un petit peu d'accroche et on a
effectivement l'impression de de
quelqu'un qui était un peu hors-sol
comme si les jours se suivaient mais que
la mémoire du jour précédent n'existe
pas on peut se projeter comme ça ouvrir
des débats des chantiers comme si rien
n'avait été fait prenons l'exemple de
son chantier sur la vie au travail
ça enfin on a entendu les réactions des
leaders syndicaux après notamment
Laurent Berger a fait remarquer que il y
a quelques années il y a eu les
ordonnances Macron il les a pas évoqué
directement mais qui ont changé un
certain nombre
un personnage comme nous tous avec
l'expérience je pense qu'il y a assez
peu de chances que ça se passe très très
bien a supposer que les syndicats
acceptent d'oublier le reste enfin bon
là-dessus qu'il faudra un peu de temps
peut-être écouter aussi les conseils de
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est-à-dire tracer ne
pas attendre trop longtemps ne pas
laisser place justement à l'opposition
ou au syndicat qui pourrait avoir
d'autres solutions comme ça c'est passé
ces derniers mois et maintenant il a
décidé il est fortement en décalage et
je pense qu'il l'assume sur la forme non
mais il l'assume profondément et j'ai
l'impression qu'il va tracer c'est un
peu ce qui m'aime prendront le train
c'est à dire moi j'avance j'avance avec
le patronat même si les images sont
catastrophiques les syndicats me
rejoindront ou pas ils vont être quand
même obligés on peut pas laisser une
place vide pour les négociations
salariales Laurent Berger de la CFDT l'a
dit déjà ce matin il l'avait dit avant
donc quelque part il avance il fait
passer et il se sacrifie pour la France
parce que il est pas sur le même niveau
que les Français nous on pense à notre
portefeuille lui il pense à l'avenir de
la France et à ce que ça va produire au
fur et à mesure c'est probablement une
erreur parce que à terme on va toujours
le ramener au terrain et à ce qui se
passe réellement dans le quotidien mais
lui il a fait ce choix on a l'impression
que là c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très très marqué alors il faut peut-être
raccorder cette allocution d'hier soir à
son déplacement demain à vos locaux 13
dans sa stratégie parce que demain il va
en Alsace et il sait bien que il va être
confronté aux Français à la colère d'une
partie des Français qui vont le ramener
sur le dossier des retraites donc
peut-être qu'il a intégré ça et et
anticiper ça c'est-à-dire qui c'est
peut-être demain que il va aller plus
loin dans sa réponse à la colère des
Français on trouve très souvent dans la
structure d'une prise de parole
d'Emmanuel Macron quelque chose un petit
peu en deux temps on a d'abord un
premier discours qui donne toujours le
sentiment d'être un peu creux en tout
cas de grand une sorte de
dégénéralité de grandes idées de grands
objectifs
et puis on voit derrière que il envoie
au créneau le premier ou la première
ministre qui va détailler en des mesures
plus concrètes qui va donner du sens
c'est celui de manière pour lui je pense
d'essayer de remettre en selle la
première ministre pour lui donner comme
feuille de mission mettre en mettre en
musique de faire des propositions donc
on peut s'attendre effectivement à la
fois du côté des déplacements de terrain
comme demain ou du côté des annonces qui
vont être faites par la première
ministre ou de toute une stratégie de
communication montrant que le
gouvernement à l'unisson est en train de
se mobiliser sur les grands objectifs
qui ont été annoncés hier de manière à
progressivement dégonfler cette idée que
on a eu des paroles un peu un peu
creuses des objectifs 100 fois entendus
et effectivement je suis rebondit sur ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure je pense
que c'est vraiment une des dimensions
très importantes beaucoup écoutent le
politique en ayant complètement perdu le
fil on ne comprend plus on se dit mais
alors le l'hôpital l'éducation mais
pourquoi c'est pas réglé encore puisque
c'est tellement urgent et donc on a le
sentiment d'un empilement d'Ann dont on
ne sait plus l'ordre dans lequel ça ça
se déroule quand est-ce que ça a
commencé quand est-ce que ça termine où
est le point d'étape pour comprendre où
on en est et les Françaises les Français
regardent ça avec le sentiment au fond
d'un état discours qui qui leur raconte
une histoire qui lui va assez peu
effectivement et en même temps l'intérêt
pour la politique est très fort
aujourd'hui dans l'opinion c'est ça qui
est c'est celle qui est fou et même on
le voit 15 millions quand même de
téléspectateurs hier pour des gens qui
sont en rejet total de en tout cas de
Macron si on en croit les médias
finalement il y a quand même il y avait
quand même une attente quelque chose
peut-être qu'il aurait pu annoncer ou
alors peut-être que ça va être dans les
prochains jours mais c'est vrai que en
tout cas cette situation assez inédite
d'un point de vue politique elle
intéresse les Français et ça je trouve
ça plutôt rassurant aussi sur la santé
quelque part de notre démocratie
c'est-à-dire comme les gens ça les
Français s'intéressent à la chose
publique en tout cas à l'action
politique et avec peut-être un espoir ou
une demande de de rénovation de de notre
fonctionnement démocratique ça on y
reviendra tout à l'heure parce que c'est
l'une des annonces là aussi qu'est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir derrière qui a été
faite hier par le prénom République mais
je voudrais revenir sur donc cette
rencontre entre Emmanuel Macron et les
représentants du patronat à l'Elysée ce
matin il y avait Emmanuel Macron et
Elisabeth borne et donc Geoffroy ou de
Baisieux qui est encore pour quelques
jours le président du du Medef il est
revenu Geoffre des yeux sur ce
calendrier et c'est son jour
ce qu'on comprend c'est que Président le
gouvernement souhaite mieux associer les
partenaires sociaux dans les discussions
futures notamment sur une discussion sur
l'emploi des seniors avec ce qui a été
enlevé par le Conseil constitutionnel et
pendant plus largement l'emploi des
seniors une eau discussion qui sera
probant sur les transitions
professionnelles et puis une discussion
sur les parcours en entreprise il y aura
aussi une loi pour transposer l'accord
partagé la valeur et plus globalement
l'idée de mieux associer les partenaires
sociaux dans les centrales travaillés
donc moi j'ai raffermir que 100 jours
c'était trop court pour arriver à des
conclusions et avoir le temps de la
négociation 100 jours c'est trop court
voilà ce que dit Geoffroy de mes yeux ce
qui est pas très surprenant on pouvait
l'imaginer on touche quand même une
contradiction du discours du pré
République Jean-Marie Pernaut il n'a pas
d'autre choix que de laisser la main aux
partenaires sociaux
ce qui est d'ailleurs ça peut être
savoureux pour ceux qui critiquent le
prêt dans la République après les avoir
mis de côté pendant son premier
quinquennat sauf qu'il doit leur laisser
du temps donc qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir
annoncer le 14 juillet sur cette
question de la la du Pacte pour pour la
nouvelle vie au travail à vrai dire
c'est 100 jours ça ressemble plutôt à un
préavis de licenciement de longue durée
pour sa première ministre
chose c'est-à-dire est-ce que pendant
ces trois mois elle sera capable de
Renaud de redonner du sens de renouer
des liens etc ça va commencer
difficilement parce que effectivement
avec les syndicats il faudra un petit
peu du temps on peut même les plus
modérés on parle toujours la CGT de la
CFDT mais il y a l'une ça il y a la CFTC
il y a des syndicats quand même qui sont
pas des syndicats radicaux c'est autour
de la table
non il y a un temps de digestion parce
que là après si vous voulez c'est des
réactions un peu de dignité bon ils ont
été bafoués enfin c'est ce qu'ils disent
mais enfin le président de la ils ont
demandé à rencontrer président de la
République pendant trois mois
il leur a dit porte close et là tout
d'un coup il promulgue et le lendemain
il dit je vais recevoir donc c'est quand
même son argument je le rappelle c'était
de dire on respecte le temps
parlementaire et ensuite je me porte
bien sûr enfin bon oui on peut toujours
habiller comme on veut mais les les
circonstances exceptionnelles peuvent
amener parfois à des rendez-vous
exceptionnels
vous pensez pas quand même les les
négociations parce que c'est le terme
qui a été employé vont penser pas
qu'elles vont démarrer sur cette
question du travail entre les débuts
mais et le 14 juillet quoi
des syndicats c'est de dire on met on a
mis la charrue avant les boeufs il
fallait discuter de tout ça avant et
donc
c'est peut-être là-dessus d'ailleurs en
plus que sur la vie du Conseil
constitutionnel sur le rip auquel peu
d'entre eux doivent croire j'imagine
enfin j'espère en tout cas
mais c'est au fond la bonne méthode
c'était celle-là c'était de commencer
par discuter parce que c'est pas tout à
fait nouveau quand même le problème de
l'emploi du seniors moi je me souviens
un des derniers travaux d'enquête que
j'ai fait on dirait c'est à 6 ans avec
d'autres avec la nake etc c'était
justement d'aller dans les entreprises
voir ce que les entreprises faisaient
c'était d'ailleurs une commande de la
DARES enfin du du du service d'études de
la du ministère du Travail essayer de
voir ce que les entreprises faisaient
c'est déjà une politique publique quand
même entamée depuis très longtemps ce
qu'on voyait était assez affligent et
d'ailleurs ça se voit dans le taux
d'emploi des seniors qui restent très en
recul par rapport au moyen-orennes même
s'il y a eu des progrès de fer jusqu'à
60 ans mais après le taux d'activité
s'effondre le patronat a l'air de
découvrir le problème c'est assez
amusant c'est pas en trois mois
effectivement qu'on va faire ce qui n'a
pas été fait et qui aurait dû être fait
au cours des 7 8 dernières années Macron
sur ce point précis il va dépendre des
partenaires sociaux si je comprends bien
c'est pas lui qui va qui va déclencher
des hausses de salaire c'est pas lui qui
va déclencher un accord sur le le CDI
senior etc très sérieux comme cette
réforme sur les retraites enfin la
question des salaires vous avez
aujourd'hui 9 dixièmes des branches dans
le minimum et le minimum de branches est
inférieur au que fait le gouvernement
c'est dans sa main il a pas besoin d'une
conférence sociale ou de choses comme ça
il y a des choses élémentaires qui
devraient être fait si tout ça est
sérieux et qui ne sont pas faites il
suffit pas de parole d'engagement etc
c'était il y a les terrains sont ouverts
il y a énormément de choses enfin la
question du salaire ça peut même pas
attendre 100 jours aujourd'hui enfin on
voit bien l'inflation s'installe le le
panier pour de des courses c'est plus
20% depuis l'an dernier on est très en
retard surtout ça donc je pense que ce
que vont attendre les Français au-delà
de ces grandes freins c'est des actes
qui n'ont pas besoin d'attendre nous
auront pas se réfugiés d'ailleurs un
dialogue social dont on n'a pas fait
grand chose pour qu'il puisse aisément
reprendre le chemin le gouvernement peut
très bien et pouvoir publique peuvent
très bien prendre l'initiative dès
maintenant sur des sujets on les connaît
ils ont été balisés depuis bien
longtemps Émilie vous étiez avec nous
hier soir pour notre émission spéciale à
22h avec un peu moins de 24 heures de
recul sur le votre analyse sur le fond
rien de très nouveau sur la forme quand
même peut-être un changement de ton un
petit changement de ton quand même parce
qu'on était loin du style provocateur
qui avait tenu Emmanuel Macron lors de
son interview vous souvenez le 22 mars à
13h c'était pas le même le même horaire
ça avait été d'ailleurs suivi d'une
journée de mobilisation assez agitée le
jeudi suivant là le temps est quand même
plus calme plus posé presque doux et
murmure parfois quelques mots et des
mots justement sonne de temps en temps
comme un met à coule pas en creux il dit
cette réforme a-t-elle été acceptée à
l'évidence non malgré les mois de
concertation un consensus n'a pas pu
être trouvé et je le regrette nous
devons en tirer tous les enseignements
alors il dit pas quels enseignements et
il dit pas vraiment ce qu'il en tire ou
comment il va tirer les enseignements de
tout ça autre changement le Président ne
parle plus de factieux et de faction
comme le 22 mars on savait assez agité
la population il entend et comprend en
tout cas dans les mots et la colère qui
s'est exprimé dans la rue il relève même
au passage que les manifestations se
sont passées en majorité dans le calme
et dans le respect des institutions ce
qui change aussi par rapport au 22 mars
personne et surtout pas moi étonnant
c'est surtout pas moi ne peut rester
sourd à cette revendication de justice
sociale et de rénovation de notre vie
démocratique donc l'écoute encore une
fois dans les mots et là mais elle est
pas forcément de mesures suivies de
mesure à la hauteur c'est ce qu'on
disait finalement une énumération de
propositions qui étaient déjà en cours
et finalement il y avait pas beaucoup
d'attentes parce que de l'autre côté on
entendait dans la rue les casseroles
retentir finalement les gens n'en
attendaient pas grand chose non plus
alors du côté des syndicats maintenant
est-ce que le ton a changé alors on l'a
dit un les syndicats sont pas autour de
la table mais en tout cas il leur a
tendu la main jusqu'à maintenant il doit
reprocher de pas avoir trouvé de
solutions ça avait fait bondir Laurent
Berger de la CFDT donc cette fois-ci se
montre plus ouvert il démarre il propose
de démarrer ce dont on parlait sans
aucune limite sans aucun tabou une série
de négociations ce nouveau pacte de la
vie au travail au programme le président
du Medef l'a dit en transition
professionnelle parcours des carrières
question des revenus l'usure
professionnelle des seigneurs évidemment
bref comme vous l'avez dit la charrue
avant les boeufs tout ce qui aurait pu
être traité avant la réforme des
retraites mais le mot est lâché en tout
cas dans la forme encore une fois ce
pacte sera construit par le dialogue
social s'il est syndicats veulent bien
venir on est loin du Macron premier
quinquennat qui n'a cessé de se passer
des corps intermédiaires il compte mieux
les associer est-ce que c'est un nouvel
aveu en creux bon faut quand même pas
pousser son manque de coopération c'est
quand même un peu vraiment en creux de
son manque de coopération avec les uns
et des autres alors pour conclure les
réactions des syndicats alors les
organisations patronales seules ont
accepté l'invitation et on a vu déjà
avant le discours d'hier mais on relève
toujours un petit peu ce côté irréel bon
parallèle sur quelle planète vit
Emmanuel Macron a dit Sophie Binet de la
CGT après son discours en gros ni la
séquence souvenir du président qui a
traversé les crises avec nous ni la
séquence émotion sur notre dame ne
réussit à les
renouer la confiance pas seulement avec
les partenaires sociaux mais avec les
Français alors évidemment je crois que
ce lien il est abîmé il est clairement
abîmé et il commence aussi à s'abîmer y
compris chez ses propres soutiens donc
c'est là où ça devient plus compliqué
c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent ces
soutiens continuer à le défendre et à le
soutenir là c'est ça commence à
s'effriter très légèrement notamment
chez les seniors chez les cadres donc ça
ça c'est c'est problématique et donc on
voit bien on a vu d'ailleurs dans le
discours d'hier aussi cette tentative et
cette tentation évidemment d'aller un
petit peu vers la droite notamment
d'essayer de retrouver
un socle de soutien beaucoup plus large
qu'il n'a aujourd'hui parce que ça va
être très difficile pour lui de
continuer à présider à gouverner avec un
socle aussi faible et puis je pense
aussi que certainement que son ambition
en tant que homme politique c'est aussi
justement d'élargir ce socle là et
d'essayer d'unir davantage au-delà même
de ses propres soutien
et quelque part il a un boulevard parce
que l'opposition est complètement kapute
alors même qu'ils auraient pu saisir
leur chance là à ce moment-là la droite
est complètement affaiblie elle est
morcelée la gauche pareil elle a
vraiment du mal à exister au-delà de la
nupcesse le RN il y a quand même
toujours cette frontière effectivement
donc
pas sûr et certain que finalement s'il y
avait vraiment des élections est-ce que
le RN serait majoritaire à l'Assemblée
nationale certainement pas enfin bon
voilà donc il y a quand même un
boulevard pour les oppositions qu'il
n'arrive pas à apprendre et Macron va
essayer évidemment de de récupérer
toutes ces tous ces potentiels soutiens
ça peut sembler étonnant ça va vous ne
coûterait ça veut dire que c'est cette
séquence là c'est trois mois de de bras
de fer de voilà de tension de d'une
France qui finalement s'affiche de plus
en plus fracturé ça ça ne modifie pas
les grands équilibres
quand on regarde les enquêtes
d'intention de votre qui ont été
réalisées par plusieurs sondeurs en cas
d'élection de législatives anticipées ou
voir en cas d'élection présidentielle on
voit c'est vrai qu'on voit à peu près le
même tiercé pour l'élection
présidentielle ça serait toujours les
trois même candidats pas dans le même
ordre au premier tour on voit causer
l'élection législatives on aurait
effectivement les trois pôles
d'un centre droit avec un leadership du
parti présidentiel d'une gauche avec un
leadership de la France insoumise et du
rassemblement national donc c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue là la situation
semble un peu figée néanmoins
effectivement plusieurs enquêtes de
pions l'ont montré on voit une vraie
fragilisation d'Emmanuel Macron dans son
cœur d'électorat avec quand même
l'utilisation du 49-3 qui a donné les
sentiments même à des macronistes
convaincus classe avait été trop loin et
qu'on ne reconnaissait plus les manuel
Macron de 2017 celui qui en appelait un
nouveau modèle politique celui dont le
premier diagnostic sur la France était
que c'était la politique qui n'allait
pas en France pas l'économie mais la
politique donc les lignes ne bougent pas
fondamentalement c'est vrai mais quand
même on voit en quête d'opinion après en
quête d'opinion que du côté du
rassemblement national et de la
perception qu'on les électeurs de la
personne de Marine Le Pen on voit
qu'elle progresse quand même voilà c'est
pas une progression spectaculaire il lui
reste des points de faiblesse
effectivement sa crédibilité exécutive
et gouvernementale mais il y a quand
même il y a quand même quelque chose qui
est en train de se passer du point de
vue de la perception de comment on peut
en sortir au fond de l'impasse dans
laquelle on est parce que le sentiment
d'un pas c'est effectivement est très
important on a l'impression qu'il a semé
justement dans les chantiers qu'il a
donné hier pas mal de choses sur la
droite qui frôle même un petit peu
l'extrême droite parce qu'on a eu le
contrôle de l'immigration illégale on a
eu la fraude fiscale et sociale on a eu
le rural l'outre-mer alors je dis dans
le désordre c'est pas du tout même
niveau mais on a quand même et on
une intense politisation les gens
partout parlaient de sujets qui les
concernent mais d'habitude on élit des
gens pour faire ça à notre place et là
dans ces moments-là on a connu ça à
d'autres moments je pense au traité
constitution européen aussi qui avait
donné un lieu qui avait été un moment
d'un temps politique on débat dans les
familles pendant les repas au restaurant
partout dans les bistrots on parlait que
de ça et même le jour le jour de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
c'est c'était le sujet du jour
descendre dans la rue indignés par
l'usage du 49.3 on se dit que c'est un
peu bizarre donc la question que vous
posez c'est à quel point ça va infuser à
long terme dans l'opinion que ça creuse
dans le social qu'est-ce que ça modifie
sur les représentations que les uns et
les autres se faisaient de leur place
dans la société d'un certain nombre de
thèmes et là-dessus je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse raisonner sur les tendances
présentes par exemple ça a beaucoup
agité la question de mais au fond c'est
quelle société c'est ça veut dire quoi
travailler longtemps les inégalités
c'est des thèmes sur lequel le
rassemblement national n'est pas est-ce
que ça et on peut se dire que avec une
gauche qui soit pas cette espèce de de
choses un peu éclatées qu'on voit
aujourd'hui mais pas de choix qui
pourrait qui pourrait construire sur la
base de ce mouvement pas pour l'immédiat
pas pour les élections demain mais ça
tombe bien il y a pas d'élection demain
peut-être les choses à long terme de la
décision de voter ou pas parce que quand
même un des gros problèmes de notre
démocratie c'est qu'une partie
importante et qui est pas également
distribué dans les groupes sociaux ne va
plus voter est-ce que des gens voient la
politique autrement aujourd'hui demain
après-demain et ça je pense que ça
reballe les cartes quand même assez
sévèrement si si on raisonne à moyen
terme on va évidemment vous donner la
question là-dessus mais d'abord
j'appelle Audrey Vitas de nous rejoindre
parce que vous m'offrez la transition
tout trouver on avait parlé de la
réforme des institutions et de et des
pistes en tout cas évoqué par Emmanuel
Macron bonsoir Audrey bienvenue puisque
le Sénat a déjà commencé à travailler
sur ces questions oui avec deux groupes
de travail trans partisans mise en place
par un Gérard Larcher il a déjà
plusieurs mois pour prendre de en avance
alors il y en a un premier qui regroupe
tous les présidents de commission et les
présidents de groupe et qui travaillent
sur les institutions de manière générale
et le second est plus centré sur la
décentralisation le cheval de bataille
du Sénat alors pour l'instant dans le
premier groupe nous en sommes au stade
des discussions mais rien n'est à bout
la place du président de la République
le retour éventuel du cumul des mandats
et même le nombre de parlementaires même
s'il y a une ligne rouge au Sénat
impossible d'avoir moins d'incénateurs
par département pour la chambre
territoire et puis on offre des
territoires et puis en off on m'explique
en fait il y a cette petite musique qui
revient sur le nombre de parlementaires
on veut les réduire mais quand les gens
ont un problème finalement ils sont bien
contents de nous trouver alors ça c'est
pour le premier groupe de travail dans
le second groupe de travail de quoi on
parle alors des mots préférés du Sénat
un décentralisation déconcentrations
simplification je le dis sur le temps de
la blague mais les effets pourraient
être très important pour les citoyens en
fait il s'agit de mettre de l'huile dans
les rouages administratives ou d'enlever
certaines strates qui ralentissent les
choses ça consiste aussi à mieux à
partir les compétences je vous donne un
exemple un maire qui voudrait par
exemple faire des aménagements sur un
cours d'eau par parfois il doit
s'adresser à deux services de l'État qui
peuvent avoir des avis contradictoires
ça donne lieu à des allers-retours à de
la paperasse pour la sénatrice Centris
Françoise Gatel c'est la spécialiste de
la décentralisation la piste qui tient
la corde c'est de redonner plus de place
au préfet dans les territoires regardez
il faut que dans les territoires l'État
soit plus fort et plus présent il semble
que le gouvernement l'admet puisqu'il
annonce la création de nouvelles
sous-préfecture et surtout au-delà du
renforcement des services de l'État au
plus près des élus on préfecture de
sous-préfecture il faut surtout que
l'État parle d'une seule voix donc pour
moi il y a pas de grands bing bang à
faire je crois que les élus n'en veulent
plus et qu'il y a moyen d'être plus
efficace en faisant vous voyez ces
sortes de petits réglages qui paraissent
petit mais qui sont essentiel et qui
permettrait surtout et c'est aussi un
des objectifs de retrouver la confiance
de nos concitoyens s'ils ne voient pas
l'efficacité de l'action publique si
c'est trop compliqué si celui qui décide
est trop loin il y a une perte de
confiance et une lassitude
alors sont les vacances parlementaires
c'est peut-être pour ça que Madame Gatel
a mis un fond qui nous fait un peu rêver
en tout cas comme elle le dit pas de on
parle de grand bouleversements nos
institutions mais finalement les pointes
détails vont peut-être être très
importants ce sera en tout cas la marque
du Sénat merci beaucoup Audrey Bruno
cotress est-ce que vous rebondissez sur
ce que vient de nous dire la sénatrice
Françoise Gatel plutôt qu'une grande
réforme des des réglages qui suffisent
sauf qu'il y a quoi il y a une demande
des Français de quoi plus de démocratie
du démocratie différente il y a
plusieurs demandes il y a une demande
qui elle est absolument fondamentale
du public citoyen soit écoutée on voit
qu'on tourne autour du pot avec les
conventions citoyennes etc il manque du
point de vue institutionnel quelque
chose de très important et là à mon avis
on ne pourra pas échapper une réforme
institutionnelle source sur cet angle là
qui est le chaînage institutionnel qui
va de ses conventions vers les
institutions comme l'Assemblée nationale
ou le Sénat pour le moment ce chaînage
n'existe pas et on va des conventions
citoyennes qui au bout du compte disent
bah voilà bah nous c'est pas on n'est
pas le fabricant de la loi maintenant et
on ne sait pas quel est le statut de
cette parole citoyenne et ça ça peut pas
continuer comme ça parce que si ça
continue comme ça c'est conventions qui
sont une vraie innovation démocratique
vont perdre aussi beaucoup de leur
crédibilité donc il y a ce voilà il y a
une demande de prise de parole il y a
une question institutionnelle qui va qui
va avec c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
simplification et une demande
d'efficacité et il y a une direction qui
ne me semble pas pouvoir être lourdement
soutenu dans l'opinion qui serait l'idée
que là où on réside là où on est né là
où on réside introduirait des
différenciations importantes sur l'accès
à la règle de à la régulation
socio-économique et donc on ne pas trop
de décentralisation il me semble que le
contenu de l'histoire de notre pays de
ce que de ce qu'est l'état
de ce qu'il représente pour les citoyens
les citoyennes on n'est pas dans une
expérience la France est pas dans une
expérience de de système décentralisé
fédéral où l'idée de dire là où on
habite peut introduire des fortes
différenciations le principe d'unicité
d'unité territoriale les Français sont
très attachés
l'idée que on étudierait pas exactement
même date au Royaume-Uni par exemple la
rentrée scolaire n'est pas au même date
en Écosse et dans l'ensemble du
Royaume-Uni en France ça me semble
quelque chose de compliqué à mettre en
oeuvre voilà donc on voit que le réglage
sera pas simple parce que les élus
locaux de leur côté ont beaucoup
d'appétit et de demandes pour avoir
davantage dans mot à dire alors ça va
est-ce que vous y croyez à cette réforme
institutionnelle parce que c'est un peu
l'arlésienne des des six années de
pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron quand même
c'est pas la première fois que que il
met le chantier en route et puis c'est
vrai qu'on sait pas trop par quel bruit
il va la prendre en fait donc là c'est
notre idée ça va peut-être être des
petits ajustements en fait je crois que
c'est c'est
Bruno le disait il y a une démarche
aussi de fond vraiment de de
renversement de paradigme c'est à dire
que les Français aujourd'hui
s'intéressent à la vie politique
considère que leur avis
vaut quasiment se la vie de politique
d'experts etc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup plus d'horizontalités
les Français considèrent que ils peuvent
avoir un avis éclairé aussi sur l'action
politique après effectivement ils savent
pas comment le mettre en en musique et
quels sont les rouages vraiment
techniques pour mettre enfin de passer
de l'idée politique à l'action politique
cet horizontalité on la retrouve parfois
à l'université on va la retrouver
parfois pas dans toutes mes dans
certaines entreprises on peut plus être
dans un fonctionnement totalement
pyramidal à l'ancienne donc ils veulent
être associé on n'a pas encore trouvé
une véritable manière de les associer
complètement et d'autant plus que
effectivement le personnel politique a
perdu en crédit et ça je crois aussi
qu'il y a un problème notamment de
professionnalisation des hommes et des
femmes politiques peut-être aussi un
effet pervers de l'absence et de la fin
du cumul des mandats c'est-à-dire que
malgré tout avant quand on cumulait des
mandats on avait quand même
de plus en plus en tout cas énormément
de contacts avec le terrain et puis des
expériences différentes en fonction des
différents mandats alors c'est vrai que
ça avait des effets pervers mais ça
avait un effet très positif c'est qu'on
pouvait vivre aussi de d'être simplement
un professionnel de la politique
aujourd'hui c'est plus compliqué et
peut-être aussi que les citoyens s'en
rendent compte et se disent on n'a pas
en face de nous des experts qui sont
finalement mieux que nous et donc il y a
aussi cette question de la
professionnalisation de la vie politique
et ça ça va être très compliqué aussi de
revenir quelque part un peu en arrière
en tout cas de changer de question de
certains ministres de ce gouvernement
qui ont
Bruno Le Maire maîtrise ses mots je
crois Jean-Marie Pernaut quand il dit au
maghreber ailleurs et c'est très bien à
qui à qui s'adresse oui je sais pas
pourquoi il a pas parlé des paradis
fiscaux parce que il en parle au moins
autant que dans les anciennes colonies
françaises non c'est un propos assez
irresponsable je trouve il est pas le
seul malheureusement à traduire
l'influence des idées d'extrême droite
sur notre vie politique je trouve
vraiment extrêmement dommageable alors
que le problème de la fraude fiscale et
sociale est un vrai problème qui
souhaiterait c'est une vraie question
qu'il faut poser sur la table on va voir
quelle mesure seront seront données dans
les dans les deux d'ailleurs la fraude
sociale et la fraude fiscale je pense
que en termes de masse la fraude fiscale
coûte beaucoup plus cher au budget de
l'État
qui défraie un peu la chronique et puis
les usages déloyaux des règles fiscales
aussi enfin ce qu'on appelle le
terme exact des enfin bref des usages
légaux mais tout de même c'est des
loyaux l'optimisation fiscale voilà bon
tout ça il y a un gros chantier et pour
les finances publiques c'est pas tout à
fait rien au moment où on parle de
économiser 12 milliards à 10 ans sur les
retraites je pense que ce chantier là
aussi était intéressant à explorer on va
on va voir quelle mesure seront
annoncées mais cette petite phrase elle
biaise le débat et c'est dommage parce
que il y a un vrai débat d'accord
les Françaises les françaises font
l'expérience parfois de que des
personnes qui gagnent beaucoup mieux
leur vie que eux payent moins d'impôts
avec toutes les niches fiscales et
toutes les mesures de défiscalisation
par exemple ok ils font aussi
l'expérience de la faute sociale
et des finances et dans son rôle d'en
appeler une gestion rigoureuse des
données publiques bien évidemment
d'autant que c'est un cheval de bataille
de longue date pour Bruno Le Maire qui a
toujours été sur cette question mais là
effectivement vous avez raison ça a bien
complètement le débat et ça fait partie
le débat sur des sur des bases qui ne
sont pas très qui ne sont pas très très
bonnes alors par ailleurs semble-t-il le
gouvernement souhaite prendre l'opinion
des Français sur comment répartir la clé
de répartition du budget où est-ce que
les impôts doivent aller mais là encore
c'est une bonne idée peut-être mais si
on fait ça il faut pas le faire sous
enfin ça doit être fait de manière
extrêmement simple d'abord c'est un des
thèmes du grand débat national
voilà donc et par ailleurs alors là ça
pourrait faire l'objet d'une très belle
délibération mais très compliqué au plan
méthodologique à mettre en oeuvre les
spécialistes de sondage le savent bien
quand on demande aux gens est-ce que
vous voulez davantage de dépenses sur
l'éducation tout le monde adore qu'il y
ait des dépenses sur les sur l'éducation
mais il faut le faire sérieusement c'est
plutôt que par exemple la défense
nationale ou à condition que donc voilà
ça demande si on le fait de le faire
très sérieusement parce qu'encore une
fois si on le fait sans le faire très
sérieusement ça va donner à nouveau le
sentiment d'une opération de
communication sans lendemain de
conclusion alors ça le vin sur sur cette
sortie de Bruno Le Maire peut-être je
pense que justement Emmanuel Macron
avait apporté quelque part une petite
innovation en parlant et un associant
fraude fiscal et fraude sociale ça
permettait un petit peu d'équilibrer et
de ne pas stigmatiser une population en
particulier et là honnêtement Bruno Le
Maire a
fait capoter les faits finalement de
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est dommage parce
qu'il y avait une tentative de
rééquilibrage qui était plutôt bienvenu
je pense merci beaucoup merci encore une
fois à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle Jean-Marie
Pernaut le titre de votre livre le
syndicalisme d'après livre qui est
publié aux éditions du détour